Apple's beloved iMac hasn't been getting
that much love recently despite being by
far the most unique Mac that's loved by
so many Mac enthusiasts including myself
in fact it's been almost two full years
since Apple's famous spring event in
2021 where they unveiled an impossibly
thin 24-inch iMac design where the
Entire Computer sits within just the
narrow chin and that was of course only
possible thanks to the new Apple silicon
M1 chair but now we just got
confirmation that apple is not only
working on the new M3 model but it's
actually in the later stages of
production so in this video I'm gonna
tell you everything you need to know
about it including the release date as
well as the mysterious 27-inch pro model
just last month Mark German from
Bloomberg gave us a huge update on the
iMac saying that apple is currently
getting it ready for launch as it has
already entered an advanced day age of
development called EVT or engineering
validation testing so it's basically
finished and they're just doing the
final testing before release now as far
as the design Mark says it'll come with
the same 24 inch display size which
makes total sense because it just got
redesigned and the previous 21.5 inch
model stayed that way for years he also
expects no change at all in terms of the
color choices which kind of makes it
seem like this new 2023 model is going
to be identical in terms of the design
with all of the changes happening on the
inside so because of that don't expect
any changes to the display quality or
features and definitely don't expect
anything like 120 hertz promotion
technology or anything like that the
main point is that the internals will be
relocated and redesigned to accommodate
the new M3 chip which is going to be the
main selling point of this new iMac now
the new m3g might not sound like a
huge deal but this chip will be the
first one built on tsmc's brand new
three nanometer process node technology
which means it'll be even more powerful
because of a huge increase in
performance per watt now that three
nanometer process is gonna matter a lot
for a battery life but as we all know
that aspect doesn't matter to a desktop
machine like the iMac since it's always
plugged in however the extra power
savings will help the chips stay more
cool and allow it to perform better
without thermal throttling which is
something we experience with the M1 iMac
especially the base model with only one
fan that wasn't even connected to the
Chip's heatsink using heat pipes and if
you're wondering how powerful it's going
to be compared to the previous M1 model
I made an entire video estimating the
performance of the M3 chip by using
leaked Apple a17 chip benchmarks and as
you can see the single core performance
is gonna be a massive 48 boost compared
to the M1 as well as an even bigger 64
multi-core performance jump it's gonna
be so fast that the M3 chip will
outperform the base model Bend 10 core
M2 Pro chip in the 2000 14 inch MacBook
Pro so that's going to be incredibly
impressive for a thirteen hundred dollar
all-in-one iMac and yes I expect the
price to stay exactly the same as it
currently is right now thirteen hundred
dollars so with the M3 chip basically
means is that it's finally going to be
fast enough for a lot of prosumers out
there who skipped the first 24 inch iMac
M1 model because it simply wasn't fast
enough for their needs but now that this
one will be faster than the base 10 core
M2 Pro it's actually going to be a
viable option for those who don't want
to wait for the 27 inch higher and iMac
models which I'll get into in just a
second and another thing to keep in mind
is that the M3 chip will likely come
with newer technology like for example
New Media engines with updated encoders
and decoders for faster video editing
and exporting there were also rumors
that Apple was working on a brand new
redesigned GPU for the a16 ship but that
ended up getting delayed until the a17
coming later this year and as we already
know the M3 chip will be using the same
cores from the a17 chip so it'll be
getting that Advantage as well including
Hardware Ray tracing support but getting
back to the iMac itself I think this one
is going to be a killer upgrade option
because you can finally get great
performance in a thin and light
all-in-one machine with less chances of
overheating and of course it'll all be
refined and fine-tuned now that Apple
has some experience with this new iMac
model I'd say that it's honestly the
perfect desktop Mac machine for kids and
teens because first of all it's very
stylish it's easy to set up and use the
operating system is very reliable and
works great with airdrop and everything
else and of course it's going to be
affordable for only thirteen hundred
dollars to get a complete Plug and Play
machine that'll last for years without
issues with viruses and malware like
other desktop PC computers have now as
far as the release date Mark Herman said
that the development is near the late
stages but it's not expected to go into
mass production for at least three
months which means that it won't ship
until the second half of the year at the
earliest now that earliest part is very
important because in my opinion the iMac
is going to come around six months after
the launch of the M3 MacBook Air so if
the M3 air launches at WWDC in in June
then the M3 iMac would still come later
in the fall of this year but if the M3
MacBook Air gets delayed until the fall
then I don't expect to see this iMac
until the spring of next year so keep
that in mind now as far as the larger
27-inch iMac model it might seem like
apple has completely given up on it but
no Mark German back in July confirmed
that apple is still working on a pro
iMac with a larger screen he said that
he imagines it would use a variation of
the M3 chip likely an M3 Pro and M3 Max
and that makes perfect sense to me
because that Mac is Meant to hit higher
performance levels but I don't think the
cooling system would be able to handle
an M3 Ultra chip since the M1 Ultra is
currently only in the Max studio and the
M2 Ultra is only expected to go into the
upcoming Mac Pro which are both very
high-end machines that need really good
cooling systems in my opinion the M3 Pro
and Max chips will probably only show up
in the summer or fall of 2024 so that's
the earliest that I would expect the 27
inch iMac to come but I think it's going
to be a killer machine for those who
need lots of performance I even think
there's a chance that Apple could do the
same thing that they're doing with the
24 inch iMac and place the entire
computer into the chin of the larger 27
inch iMac model now that might seem
crazy because those faster chips require
a bigger cooling system but the larger
27 inch iMac would technically have a
longer and larger chin in order to stay
proportional and the design would be
thicker as well while still looking
great thanks to the bigger display size
Apple would likely Jam pack it with
extra ports as well just like we have in
the 14 and 16 inch MacBook Pros so it's
really going to be a professionals dream
come true including myself since I used
to work on an old iMac Pro for the last
couple of years and I'm currently
waiting for an apple silicon version to
come out but of course I skipped out on
the 24 inch model because I needed more
display space for multitasking and
researching so hopefully the iMac comes
next year so with all that said if
you're excited for the new M3 iMac then
comment your thoughts down below and
click the circle about to subscribe for
more videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
thank you